we are living in a special century the
first you know its history when one
species is empowered to control the fate
of the entire biosphere to jumpstart a
transition to entities that far
transcend our limitations or to take a
darker view to foreclose the immense
future potential and leave in an archaic
and depleted planet so how can we
forestall catastrophes and ensure a
brighter future we need to think
globally
I mean you think rationally empowered by
21st century technology but guided by
value that science itself can't provide
above all we need to think long term
secular organization the long now
foundation will create a simple contrast
romantically with our country per face
of short-termism in the cavity
underground a massive clock will be
built designed to tick for 10,000 years
to resolve is a different time every day
over that expanse of time those of us
who visited this century will
contemplate a monument built to outlast
the cathedrals and will be inspired to
hope that 100 centuries from now it will
indeed still be ticking and at some of
our progeny will still be there to visit
it and they gave the very last word to
one of my scientific heroes the eloquent
biologist Peter Medawar I quote
the bells are topher mankind I like the
bells of Alpine cattle they're attached
to our own neck and it must be our fault
they don't make a cheerful and melodious
sound thank you very much
[Applause]